bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir et la
grande figure historique du journal
Libération qu'il a fondé en
1973 au cimetière il y a toujours 50 ans
on va parler évidemment de cette
anniversaire à hors-série exceptionnelle
sort en kiosque demain les combats les
heures de gloire de Liber les passages à
vide aussi le journal il a pas mal
changé vous nous direz sur l'esprit
d'origine libérale libertaire est
toujours là ou pas on a du temps on en
parlera ensemble tout à l'heure mais on
commence avec notre grand débat ce soir
sur les basses salaires les travailleurs
pauvres sont plus nombreux dans le pays
et plus pauvres avec l'inflation le
gouvernement espère en faire la nouvelle
priorité nationale pour tourner la page
des retraites vous le savez certaines
branches sont en dessous du minimum
légal alors sommes-nous condamnés à une
société de smicard c'est notre grand
débat avec nos invités dans un instant
sur ce plateau avant de retrouver à
20h15 les parties pris de nos affranchis
et puis Bourbon Express bien sûr
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée voilà
pour le menu ce soir vous me suivez
serjulie
[Musique]
elles sont fans de ménage caissières
web-soignante ils sont charists
magaziniers ou travailleurs des
plateformes tous en première ligne
pendant le covid tous subissent de plein
fouet l'inflation et tous sont quasiment
ou presque au SMIC et passent même leur
carrière au SMIC alors sommes-nous
condamnés à une société de smicard la
pauvreté au travail est-elle une
fatalité bonsoir Charlotte Parmentier
Lecoq bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes député renaissance du Nord
vous étiez la rapporteur du projet de
loi pouvoir d'achat qui a été adopté à
l'été dernier en face de vous Philippe
bruns bonsoir merci d'être là de députés
socialiste de l'heure membre de la
commission des finances et le Parti
socialiste qui a des propositions à
faire sur les salaires bonsoir gilberset
économiste professeur à la Neoma
Business School à Paris enfin bonsoir
Karen Gournay bonsoir vous êtes
syndicaliste secrétaire confédéral de
force ouvrières la mobilité salariale et
bien c'est vous les partenaires sociaux
qui en avaient la charge on verra ce
qu'il est possible ou non de négocier
avec le patronat serguly les salaires
c'est un combat de Libé de toujours
mais évidemment votre regard nous
intéresse dans ce débat va commencer par
planter le décor avec Stéphane
blackovski bah ça a l'air inflation
pourquoi le travail ne paie pas assez
dans le pays et que veut faire Emmanuel
Macron il a deux secondes c'est parti
top chrono
le chrono de Blacko je me retourne pour
vous accueillir bonsoir Stéphane bonsoir
Myriam bonsoir à toutes et tous alors
qu'est-ce qui ne va pas donc ce sont pas
des basses salaires qui sont rattrapés
par l'inflation qui ont du mal à boucler
leurs fins de moi et c'est même plus
grave que ça puisque quand on parle des
Français qui touchent pas plus que le
SMIC c'est à dire le SMIC ou moins et
bien ils ont même du mal à remplir leur
frigo c'est un sondage de l'Ifop qui
nous donnait ses chiffres voyez plus de
80% ont arrêté de consommer ce qui coûte
trop cher la moitié ou plus même on
réduit des quantités on a même 40% de
des Français donc qui touchent le débat
salaire qui ont sauté un repas du coup
forcément le Président on est conscient
il s'inquiète et récemment il a dénoncé
justement les branches professionnelles
selon vous parliez dans les grilles
salariales commencent en dessous du
salaire minimum on écoute
aujourd'hui allons travailler pour
maintenant très vite trouver une réponse
dans tous ces métiers qui sont
insuffisamment payés qui sont souvent
les métiers de première et deuxième
ligne dont on a eu besoin pendant la
période covid et qui continue à avoir
des salaires minimum dans leurs branche
qui sont inférieures au minimum légal
alors ce qui est amusant c'est quand
même que Emmanuel Macron sur ce sujet il
est un petit peu en retard on va dire il
a carrément un an de retard en fait sur
ce que disait Laurent Berger il disait
exactement la même chose il y a un an
avant les présidentielles c'est à dire
que avant de savoir qui était élu il
disait que pour la CFDT la priorité ce
serait que toutes les grilles salariales
de toutes les branches professionnelles
commencent au SMIC en écoute ce que je
souhaite c'est que le gouvernement quel
qu'il soit
et bien il impose aux branches
professionnelles dans les six mois
d'avoir des négociations pour que leur
minima de branches ne soit pas inférieur
au SMIC alors si surprenant mais on voit
bien que Macron hébergé sont quand même
d'accord sur ce sujet alors donc sur
quoi ils sont d'accord je vais essayer
de vous expliquer regardez quand on
parle des effets de l'inflation
notamment sur la vie des Français le
SMIC est indexé sur l'inflation il a
augmenté quasiment de 10% c'est 18
derniers mois l'inflation elle donc plus
qu'un inflation en revanche pour les
salaires des moins bien payés et bien
ils ont augmenté et le pire c'est que
dans certaines branches professionnelles
alors bien sûr on a pris la pire pour
que ça soit démonstratif en l'occurrence
dans le caoutchouc les griffes ça n'a
rien ils commencent en dessous du SMIC
regarde 1610 alors que le SMIC c'est
1709 brut aujourd'hui alors attention
personne n'est payé en dessous du SMIC
en fait puisque l'employeur compense
avec une prime soit un peu plus de
salaire mais les fesses c'est que votre
coefficient
en fonction de votre durée de
l'entreprise progresse soyez au bout de
10 ans vous avez quasiment beaucoup plus
d'expérience forcément mais au bout de
10 ans bah votre salaire il est toujours
en dessous du SMIC donc oui le SMIC
augmente mais les autres salaires ont
tendance à stagner donc on se dit bah
moi je vais pas je ne vais pas bosser
dans le caoutchouc évidemment mais il y
a d'autres domaines où ça je regardais
j'ai des enseignants par exemple voilà
la musique qui se trouve dévalorisé par
rapport au SMIC c'était deux fois le
SMIC à 40 ans aujourd'hui c'est à peine
1 fois plus et donc forcément on a des
problèmes de recrutement dans ce métier
comme dans d'autres d'où l'inquiétude de
Laurent Berger qui s'inquiète d'une
smicardisation de la classe moyenne
c'est-à-dire que tout le monde va finir
par être payé en tout cas plus de la
moitié des fois la moitié des Français
vont être payés au SMIC on l'écoute le
SMIC il est devenu trop souvent la norme
y compris quand vous développez des
compétences quand vous avez une un
déroulement de carrière etc et bien vous
pouvez faire preuve d'investissement
professionnel de compétences acquises
évidemment par la par votre travail etc
et continuer d'être payé au smic alors
ça c'était il y a un an et vous allez
voir comme c'est amusant parce qu'il se
trouve que le président Macron était
exactement d'accord une fois de plus
avec Laurent Berger bah oui vous savez
qu'il veut redonner le goût du travail
aux Français et donc pour ça et bien il
faut revaloriser les carrières en
l'écoute
on doit travailler les carrières c'est
pas une loi qui changera les carrières
parce qu'on n'est pas une économie
administrée mais il faut remettre sur le
terrain
le dialogue social pour que les
carrières permettent de mieux gagner sa
vie bref moi j'ai l'impression que
Macron hébergé contrairement ce qu'on
pourrait croire faut vraiment d'accord
sur pas mal de choses et c'est tellement
dommage qu'ils soient fâché sur cette
question de la réforme des retraites moi
je me demande mais qui suis-je pour dire
ça s'il aurait pas fallu commencer
d'abord par les carrières et les
salaires et après elle recule et monte
le son merci merci pour cette conclusion
piquante Stéphane dacoche qui je vais
commencer par les observateurs et j'irai
vers les élus juste après gilberset
qu'est-ce qui se passe en France pour
bien comprendre le phénomène pourquoi
pour reprendre l'expression du président
les salaires sont écrasés autour du SMIC
soit un peu plus on parlera des branches
qui sont en dessous du SMIC mais déjà
pourquoi la mobilité salariale ne
fonctionne pas pour les bas salaires
dans le pays je dirais qu'il y a deux
raisons à cela la première c'est que la
négociation collective est insuffisante
sur les questions salariales alors même
que les partenaires sociaux et les
syndicats de salariés montrent une très
forte la capacité de mobilisation dans
la période actuelle et bien en ce qui
concerne les salaires cette capacité de
mobilisation semble assez faible dans un
pays comme la France quand on se compare
à des pays par exemple comme l'Allemagne
alors ça c'est une raison une raison
forte dans un contexte il faut le dire
ou les augmentations du SMIC ont été
fortes et répétées il y a eu deux
augmentations du SMIC l'année 2021 il a
eu trois en 2022 donc même des branches
qui s'alignent en quelque sorte sur le
SMIC sont rattrapés par l'augmentation
suivante et en 2023 on en a une bien sûr
au 1er janvier de 1,80% et on en aura
une autre le 1er mai ou le premier juin
prochain donc c'est de la faute des
partenaires sociaux alors les syndicats
ou le patronat parce qu'en général c'est
les patrons qui doivent accepter les
augmentations de salaire et puis il y a
une autre raison fondamentale c'est que
les gains en termes de revenus associés
à une augmentation du salaire pour
quelqu'un qui est au SMIC sont très
faibles très très faibles quoi ça vaut
pas le coup pourquoi parce que en
financièrement pour le salarié
d'augmentation
énormément de prestations plus que l'on
tout autre pays
les aides sociales des aides sociales et
ces prestations sont évidemment
dégressives avec les revenus du travail
c'est logique ils sont pas universelles
elles sont conditionnées aux revenus du
travail donc on perd des aides par
exemple au logement si on monte un petit
peu du travail augmente est-ce que nous
avons montré dans le rapport du Groupe
d'experts sur le SMIC que j'ai l'honneur
de présidé c'est que la France est le
pays dans lequel les gains en termes de
revenus nets associés aux progressions
salariales sont les plus faibles de tous
les pays avancés de tous les pays de
l'OCDE 38 pays de l'OCDE on a 30 qui ont
un salaire minimum parmi ces 30 le
salarié lui-même dans l'environnement
social français qui n'a pas intérêt à
être augmenté c'est un pays dans lequel
les gains en termes de revenus d'une
augmentation de salaire en bas l'échelle
des salaires ces gains sont les plus
faibles du fait de la dégressivité de
prestation massive alors karengournet
pour les partenaires sociaux puis
d'abord les experts ensuite les élus
pour les propositions première argument
c'est de la faute des partenaires
sociaux au fond il n'avaient qu'à
réussir à négocier qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça c'est plutôt le patronat
qui traîne les pieds c'est ça alors je
pense qu'au-delà de la problématique de
la négociation de branche en effet vous
êtes bien concernés pour savoir que une
négociation il y a une obligation de
moyens pas de résultats donc il faut
être deux pour négocier et forcément
quand bien même nous avons nous
organisations syndicale envie de pousser
pour obtenir des augmentations de
salaire bien souvent elle se limite
simplement à une mise en conformité au
SMIC et donc si on négocie des minimas
conventionnels rallaient pas crètes et
qu'on s'en tient à la conformité au SMIC
nécessairement à la prochaine
régularisation hop boum toutes les
branches elles retombent en dessous en
dessous du SMIC ça c'est un élément
important nous avions à plusieurs
reprises à force Ouvrière demander au
gouvernement de potentiellement
retrouver les moyens de contraindre
d'une façon ou d'une autre quand même le
patronat à être un peu plus enclin
comment précisément quels proposer la
conditionnalité par exemple des
exonérations sociales
qui sont dire un versement enfin une
obtention des exonérations
qui pourraient dépendre de d'une branche
qui est ou non conforme au SMIC
bon mais moi il y a quelque chose qui
d'orait déjà me choc au delà du fait que
les partenaires sociaux ont une
responsabilité je pense que le
gouvernement en fortune y compris dans
le fait de refuser depuis 13 ans un
véritable coup de pouce au SMIC qui est
un levier indispensable et rapide et
efficace pour essayer de faire en sorte
un effet aussi sur les salaires un tout
petit peu au-dessus ces mécanique on
augmente le SMIC et l'échelle augmente
pour nous l'augmentation du SMIC c'est
un moteur dans les négociations de
branches c'est à dire qu'à partir du
moment où il y a un coup de pouce
significatif qui est donné au minima
conventionnel on toute la grille qui
s'inspire de cette dynamique alors les
élites Charlotte Parmentier le coq
augmenter le SMIC serait une des
réponses pour essayer de relancer la
mobilité salariale autour du SMIC un peu
au-dessus également dans les entreprises
déjà là-dessus pourquoi on l'a vu
pendant le débat sur le pouvoir d'achat
si vous avez systématiquement refusé
c'est une des réponses effectivement
quand il y a des augmentations du SMIC
ça induit que certaines branches doivent
revoir leur négociation et revoir leur
seuil minimum de rémunération et ça
c'est des choses qu'on a renforcé aussi
dans la loi pouvoir d'achat ou l'État
peut effectivement venir de manière un
peu plus coercitive forcer par le biais
de fusion de branches
à négocier
qu'on va voir un sujet dans un instant
mais pourquoi pourquoi tout simplement
ne pas augmenter pas simplement
réévaluer sur l'inflation il est
augmenté le SMIC il est quand même
augmenté il quand même augmenter
plusieurs fois il peut y avoir aussi des
coups de pouce nous ce qu'on pense c'est
qu'il faut aussi laisser le dialogue
social faire son travail pour pousser
les augmentations de rémunération et par
ailleurs on a plutôt aussi une démarche
qui est de finalement dégager des marges
de manœuvre aux entreprises pour leur
permettre d'avoir du souffle et leur
permettre justement de faire ces
exonérations on peut faire ses
augmentations
il y a quand même des branches qui ont
renégocié parce qu'il y a deux effets
j'allais dire d'un côté on leur libère
des marges parce qu'on a baissé les
impôts de production on a baissé les
charges aussi pour leur permettre de
d'embaucher de se développer
et de l'autre côté on fait reculer le
chômage progressivement et ça ça donne
aussi un rapport de force un peu plus
important pour pour les partenaires
sociaux donc il y a les faits sur les
bas salaires très bas salaires qui sont
en dessous du SMIC où on a renforcé la
coercition dans la pouvoir d'achat parce
que c'est vrai de ce fait il y a des
branches qui étaient à la traîne et
qu'il était on va y venir sur les
branches en dessous du SMIC mais déjà il
faut faire confiance non mais pas que
faire confiance il y a un peu de
conversion
favorable surtout les aides Fillon
toutes les exonérations de cotisation
salariale juste au-dessus du SMIC
jusqu'à 1,6 Smic elle entreprise elle se
dit si j'augmente je perds mes avantages
donc j'augmente pas alors je pense que
c'est là où il y a encore des marges
manœuvre et sans doute en travail à
conduire à approfondir donc vous êtes
supprimé ces exonérations salariales sur
les je peux pas vous répondre débutants
sur quelque chose qu'avec des effets de
bord énorme c'est des choses qui sont à
l'étude actuellement on a un groupe de
travail avec les députés Renaissance on
est en train enfin les députés de la
Major puisqu'il y a aussi les deux
autres groupes de la Majo on est en
train de préparer des réflexions sur la
future loi travail qui arrive et pour
nous la question de la rémunération
c'est un élément donc c'est c'est
possible c'est sur la table on réfléchit
et d'ailleurs on auditionne aussi les
partenaires sociaux là sur la corde
nationale interprofessionnelle de
partage de la valeur on réfléchi sur les
modalités qu'on pourrait prendre et les
allégements et après je me tais pardon
pour mon collègue les allèges mon fiant
en particulier ça fait partie des points
qu'on a en ligne de mire parce qu'on
voit bien que il y a des effets de seuil
qui font qu'à un moment donné ça peut
bloquer les progressions de salaire
les blocages
Philippe brain bon bah ça peut bouger
magnifiquement donc on a fait on a trois
grands problèmes qui expliquent cette
situation de faible rémunération du
travail en France le premier c'est qu'on
est le pays européen qui subventionne le
plus les bas salaires allez je mens
Juppé allez je m'en baladure allez je
m'en Aubry allègement Fillon et après il
y a eu le pacte de responsabilité sous
François Hollande si bien qu'aujourd'hui
jusqu'à 1,6 Smic dans une situation où
vous payez pas beaucoup de cotisations
sociales et quand vous passez au dessus
de 1,6 m là écoute ça coûte plus cher et
donc on voit effectivement exister une
trappe à bas salaire c'est à dire que au
dessus de 1,6 mix ça devient compliqué
pour les entreprises elles ne vont plus
au dessus donc il est temps d'en finir
pour vous avec ces allègements il faut
vraiment mettre cela sur la table est
extrêmement sérieusement deuxième sujet
qui est grave c'est la question
évidemment des branches professionnelles
70% aujourd'hui des branches
professionnelles prévoient des débuts de
rémunération qui sont inférieurs au SMIC
cela a été expliqué alors on en a voulu
vous montrer un sujet là-dessus mais je
vous laisse poursuivre c'est un certain
nombre de métiers qui sont
particulièrement mal rémunérés en raison
de leurs conditions d'exercice le cas
des aides à domicile qui pour la plupart
gagnent moins de 1000 euros par mois
parce qu'elles ne sont pas payées entre
les différentes personnes
le temps partiel subit alors on
travaille le matin très tôt on finit le
tarte le soir très tard et entre chaque
endroit où on se rend pour donner une
toilette aider une personne
âgée et bien on n'est pas payé
aujourd'hui les aides à domicile elles
sont pas payées elles sont défrayées
pour leur trajet mais elles ne sont pas
payées c'est pas considérés comme du
temps de travail c'est incroyable sa
raison pour laquelle pour ce dernier
point il faut une loi je crois là il
faut vraiment une loi pour donner un
statut à ces métiers du soin à ses
métiers du lien qui sont
particulièrement mal rémunérés
à cette étape du débat ça vous semble
logique on parle au des salaires et des
moyens finalement de sortir de cette
crise des retraites maintenant on a pris
de choses à l'envers mais ça fait quand
même très longtemps qu'on a les mêmes
discussions donc c'est pas j'ai
l'impression que j'ai déjà entendu ces
débats depuis
le bas salaire
est plus et donc ça devient de
plus en genre de plus en plus grave il
se trouve que l'inflation est revenue
donc ça a gravé les choses on a vu que
les choses étaient plus graves que
finalement on en avait la mémoire mais
c'est je se déballe est très ancien les
trappes bah ça a l'air sont inconnus
depuis longtemps c'est comme la banquise
elle est connue qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire on va
pas dans un instant qui sont en dessous
du SMIC mais sur ce que dit Philippe
Brun Gilbert 7 toutes ces métiers à
temps partiel subit parce qu'il y a des
horaires fractionnés parce que on ne
tient pas compte des trajets parce que
les employeurs disent non je ne veux pas
vous donner un temps plein parce qu'on
fonctionne à l'intime qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire là-dessus ces métiers en
particulier trois petites choses
première chose l'idée de dire les
branches qui gardent des minimas
inférieur au SMIC faudrait leur
supprimer les allégements de
contribution sociale c'est quelque chose
qu'on a étudié qui qui était d'ailleurs
rentré dans le droit français dans le
droit positif en 2008 qu'on a abrogé en
1988 pardon on a abrogé en 1993 pour une
raison simple c'est qu'il y avait un
problème de constitutionnalité voilà et
donc on a été obligé les décideurs
publics parce que des entreprises
pouvaient être pénalisées pour une
décision qui a été prise au niveau de la
branche et donc pour n'importe quelle
constitutionnalisme vous voyez c'est
c'est pour les maths de pénaliser
quelqu'un pour un acte dont il est pas
directement responsable
ça c'est la première chose
deuxième chose quand même juste pour
revenir sur ce que dit Madame on est un
pays curieux on attend toutes l'état moi
quand je voyage partout en Europe je
vois des partenaires sociaux qui disent
que l'État ne se mêle pas des salaires
c'est notre problème j'étais en
Allemagne au Pays-Bas par exemple ce
qu'ils font traditionnellement c'est
qu'ils alignent leur valorisation du
salaire minimum sur le résultat des
négociations collectives de branches en
disant c'est une sorte d'extension à
l'ensemble de l'économie de ce que vous
qui avez les clés du camion qui
négociait vous vous arrivez à obtenir
donc on élargit à tout le monde mais
c'est vous qui devez vous battre sur le
terrain et d'ailleurs encore une fois on
a vu récemment en Allemagne des
augmentations prodigieuses qui ont été
accordées dans certaines branches avec
également
un pays où on constate aujourd'hui que
les syndicats ont une forte capacité de
mobilisation sur les salaires c'est le
bon moment comme vous le disiez madame
il y a des difficultés de recrutement
c'est le moment de négocier en quelque
sorte alors maintenant sur les temps
partiels je vous renvoie au rapport
véritable statut pour ces salariés
spécifiques
que je préside on a consacré 40 pages
sur cette question de la pauvreté au
travail et des temps partiels parce que
si on s'intéresserait réellement à la
pauvreté au travail on parle des temps
partiels un chiffre un chiffre sur
l'ensemble des salariés 6,9% sont
pauvres sur ceux qui sont à temps
partiel plus du double 15 % 15,1% et
pour ceux qui travaillent 50% d'un temps
plein ou moins on en est à 24% en termes
de taux de pauvreté le premier facteur
de pauvreté c'est le nombre d'heures
travaillées le deuxième facteur de
pauvreté il faut quand même l'évoquer
c'est la situation familiale les
travailleurs qui sont voilà les familles
monoparentales
31% de taux de pauvreté
des chiffres à lui
le diagnostic on va parler des branches
mais là j'aimerais vraiment que vous
répondiez à la proposition de Philippe
Brun est-ce que c'est possible de donner
un statut pour peut-être obligé un temps
plein pour ces travailleurs aux horaires
fractionnés qui ne peuvent pas faire le
SMIC qu'ils aimerait faire parce qu'ils
ne peuvent pas travailler les
on va pas jamais administrer à ce point
là les entreprises enfin ni les
associations par contre sur ce sur cette
activité là sur ce secteur d'activité
c'est le gouvernement qui a soutenu qu'à
encouragé qui a poussé les partenariats
sociaux dans le secteur associatif à
renégocier à négocier un avenant
l'avenant 43 qui est assez connue dans
le dans le secteur de la domicile et qui
a accompagné les hausses de salaire que
ça représentait ça représentait des
hausses conséquentes en moyenne 15% ce
qui est vraiment pas du tout négligeable
ensuite je pense que c'est aussi
accompagner les structures
mieux recruter et à mieux améliorer les
conditions de travail à mieux aussi
organiser les agendas les modes
ces employeurs à mieux organiser les
agendas si vous donnez pas un statut
comment les oblige enfin on les incite
alors il y a plusieurs il y a plusieurs
méthodes qui peuvent être effectivement
oui liés à des primes qualités notamment
on l'a introduit cette déjà dans la loi
d'une prime qualité de 3 euros de
l'heure pour les employeurs qui
effectivement ont des actions en termes
de qualité de vie au travail de prise en
compte des déplacements etc et puis
encore une fois c'est le fait aussi
qu'elle soit en peine de recrutement qui
les oblige à revoir aussi leurs copies
sur comment est-ce qu'ils sont un peu
plus attractifs les pénuries étaient les
aides à domicile à embaucher elles
veulent dans leurs emplois du temps dans
leur conditions après elles sont elles
parce que c'est un métier très féminin
mais elles sont pas encline à travailler
à temps plein c'est pas forcément un
souhait c'est il y a aussi des métiers
dans lesquels il y a un vrai souhait de
travail à temps partiel mais où
l'articuler 40%
40% des temps
avoir un temps plein donc c'est quand
même beaucoup plus vieux c'est sur les
familles monoparentales c'est ce qui a
été dit ou effectivement c'est très
compliqué et c'est pourquoi on vous
aussi développer un service public de
l'enfance pour vraiment aider à garder
les enfants et ça c'est aussi des
éléments qui seront en France travail
pour les familles monoparentales dans
les accompagnements je vous donne la
parole promis j'aime bien quand tout le
monde veut parler mais on va faire un
gros plan sur justement ces branches
parce que vous avez largement parlé mais
pour bien comprendre ces techniques
pourquoi il existe des branches
professionnelles en dessous du seuil du
SMIC quels sont les plus mauvais élèves
décryptages les amants d'un gamin
pour les Français il ne suffit déjà pas
combien est-ce que vous savez un peu
1355 je crois et est-ce que selon vous
il faudrait l'augmenter
je pense qu'il faudrait l'augmenter
effectivement parce que en tout cas
vivant à Paris avec un SMIC c'est super
compliqué je pense 1700 brut bien sûr
mais après tous les prélèvements on se
retrouve c'est pas 1300 et la vie
devient tellement cher je pense que
c'est c'est nul quand même et pour vous
il faudrait l'augmenter du coup je
dirais que le SMIC doit être au moins le
net plus ou moins 1600 SMIC comme
salaire minimum et pourtant au 30 mars
2023 selon le ministère du Travail 83
branches sur les 161 qui compte plus de
5000 salariés ont des minimas en dessous
du SMIC c'est le cas des branches cinéma
habillement
caoutchouc ou encore agence de voyage
alors que le SMIC est revalorisé au 1er
janvier chaque année et en cours d'année
si l'inflation est importante ce n'est
pas le cas des minimum conventionnels
qui se négocient dans les branches
professionnelles certaines peuvent donc
afficher des salaires bien inférieurs au
SMIC attention cela ne veut pas dire que
leur salarié sont payés en dessous du
SMIC c'est interdit l'employeur est tenu
de compléter pour atteindre le salaire
minimum en vigueur mais cela joue sur
l'évolution du salarié même en
gravissant les échelons il pourra rester
bloqué au niveau du SMIC de quoi créer
un décalage si le SMIC à sensiblement
augmenter ses derniers mois le salaire
des ouvriers et des employés a progressé
beaucoup moins rapidement
[Musique]
Karen gournet pour ces branches
professionnelles qui sont en dessous du
SMIC qu'est-ce que Force Ouvrière
propose qu'on traite concrètement très
concrètement là il y a un effet un peu
particulier tout de même à la situation
c'est qu'on a connu énormément de
régularisation du SMIC on en a connu
comme vous le disiez tout à l'heure deux
en 2021 3 en 2022 donc le problème c'est
que les branches vont à peine eu le
temps de se réunir que concrètement
quelques mois après les minimas
conventionnels redescendaient en dessous
du SMIC donc il y a aussi le problème du
temps de la négociation parce que même
si la loi prévoit que les branches sont
à se réunir dans les trois mois suivant
la régularisation du SMIC s'il y a des
niveaux inférieurs qui ont des coule
somme toutes historiquement on a du mal
à comprendre comment une branche
professionnelle peut décider cette
espèce d'arrangement entre d'un côté
l'employeur qui complète au SMIC et puis
un démarrage plus bas que le SMIC ça
devrait pas être interdit ça mais il y a
une solution simple automaticité si on
acceptait une automaticité et une remise
à niveau automatique des minima
conventionnels
il y a un problème manifestement toute
façon on peut même si le minima de la
branche est inférieur au SMIC le
l'emploi il est quand même obligé de
payer au SMIC il faut pas imaginer il
est obligé de payer il est obligé de
payer au SMIC mais ça ça contribue à se
faire une augmentation de salaire il
obtient une augmentation de salaire sur
son salaire de base et pas sur son
salaire compléter avec le complément
SMIC ce qui fait que parfois
l'augmentation qui est des décidez dans
l'entreprise parce que nos camarades
font grève dans les entreprises si on en
a plein qui sont mobilisés ces derniers
temps justement pour faire valoir des
augmentations de salaire et donc les
syndicats sont présents et ne font pas
rien
dans ces cas-là quand il y a 2 %
d'augmentation accordée en entreprise et
bien parfois en réalité entre le
complément SMIC qui était versé aux
salariés et les 2%, il y a pas de
différence donc vous êtes toujours
finalement tant que la branche n'est pas
conforme au SMIC avec des augmentations
salariales d'entreprise qui s'appliquent
sur une base erronée donc l'augmentation
de salaire obtenue en entreprise elle
est totalement diluée en réalité les
brins qu'est-ce que vous proposez
à faire moi je pense quand même malgré
tout c'est comme ça ça vous sonne en
France dans telle faut que l'État pousse
aujourd'hui je pense vraiment fortement
les branches à se saisir du sujet
permettez-moi de revenir sur les temps
de partiels subis
bon les gens qui travaillent ici qui
sont intermittents je crois qu'il y en a
LCP vous avez le temps du spectacle et
bien quand il travaille pas ils ont une
subvention ils ont le régime d'assurance
chômage leur verse un salaire quand il
travaille pas et bah c'est pas le cas
pour les femmes de ménage c'est pas le
cas pour les caissières c'est pas le cas
pour les aides à domicile et les aides
soignantes je crois qu'il faudrait
aujourd'hui même de cumuler l'action
d'heures qui permettra un régime comme
celui-là
qui travaillait pas toute l'année bien
et on a décidé c'est très bien que pour
conventionné ces métiers là on permet à
ces gens de vivre quand ils ne
travaillent pas et moi je trouve cela
scandaleux que finalement le devenir
d'un projectionniste d'un quelqu'un qui
travaille dans le spectacle soit du
point de vue de l'État plus favorisé que
quand on est aide à domicile voilà donc
je crois qu'il faut aujourd'hui prendre
à bras le corps ce problème là voilà à
bras le corps là et quand on parle même
des familles monoparentales très souvent
il y a un cumul on est famille
monoparentales merci célibataire aide à
domicile ou assistante maternelle et on
cule l'ensemble en fait des difficultés
et aujourd'hui ce film parental 43% 83%
sont des femmes 43% vivent ceux de
pauvreté s'agissant des femmes voilà
donc on a un vrai sujet à faire vous
répondrez sur la question une forme de
régime
c'est envisageable créer une forme de
régime pour que finalement le temps non
travaillé soit complété ou subventionné
par l'État mais là je vois pas très bien
dans quel cadre ça enfin à quel point ça
répond enfin quand on a un statut
d'intermittent bien parce que on
travaille par intermittence en fonction
des besoins des émissions des qu'on peut
se trouver c'est pas du tout le cas de
des aides à domicile par intermittence
pour une personne
âgée vous travaillez seulement le matin
seulement le soir pas en journée on
prend pas en compte vos déplacements
enfin c'est quand même incroyable que on
puisse passer à la conscription de la
France périurbaine on passe des
kilomètres en voiture les kilomètres
passés en voiture ils sont même pas
financés on paye seulement l'essence
assez fan donc il faut aujourd'hui une
loi pour donner un statut j'en suis
absolument absolument convaincu encore
une fois regardons comment on traite
bien mieux le secteur culturel en France
que le secteur des aides à domicile
pour répondre à votre question il serait
quand même curieux que à partir du
moment où un chef d'entreprise
introduit des périodes non travaillées à
l'intérieur d'une journée de travail ça
entraîne une dépense pour la
collectivité pour vous pour moi et
cetera certains métiers ça serait quand
même un petit peu curieux alors comment
responsabiliser les les entreprises et
les partenaires sociaux c'est quelque
chose de complexe il faut éviter les les
mauvaises recettes je rappelle qu'il y a
des études qui ont été faites par
exemple sur la réforme de 2014 vous
voyez qu'il y a imposé un certain nombre
d'heures travaillées pour les temps
partiels 24 heures pour éviter les temps
partiels trop court les études une à une
par exemple de Pauline carry là qui qui
fait autorité qui est assez récente qui
nous montre que ça détruit les emplois
c'est ça poussait des gens vers la
pauvreté ça réduit le nombre d'heures
dans les entreprises concernées il y a
des personnes qui sont plus pauvres
après qu'avant alors que justement
l'objectif c'est de réduire la pauvreté
et pour répondre à Madame moi je suis
stupéfait la négociation de branches
encore une fois doit relever du travail
des partenaires sociaux il faut on voit
bien cette question de l'indexation des
salaires sur les prix c'est quand même
un gouvernement socialiste qui en 1983
le gouvernement Mauroy interdit par la
loi l'indexation des salaires sur
l'inflation parce qu'on allait dans le
mur
aller dans le mur c'est un gouvernement
de gauche avec
communication
qui est indexé sur l'inflation c'est le
salaire minimum et surtout il faut en
rester là il faut pas déposséder les
partenaires sociaux de leur travail le
mot de la fin il y a une chose dont on a
pas du tout parler mais il y a un accord
sur le partage de la valeur qui a été
négociée cette fois-ci ça a marché avec
le Medef avec les
partenaires sociaux ça est-ce que pour
ceux dont on parle les plus précaires
les bas salaires il peut y avoir des
conséquences positives pour eux ou ils
travaillent dans des entreprises qui ne
seront pas concernées alors si je peux
juste me enfin
je termine en un mot quand on regarde
bien donc deux femmes ont été
interrogées et visiblement elles étaient
plutôt encline à vouloir une
augmentation du Smic et elles n'ont pas
réfléchi à la possibilité que ça vienne
diminuer leur prestations sociales moi
je trouve ça c'est un peu comme la
réforme des retraites
pas d'intérêt accepter une augmentation
du Smic parce que leur prestations
sociales s'en verrai diminuer d'autant
donc moi j'ai plutôt vous dites il faut
l'augmenter on est plutôt dans une phase
de mieux emploi ça freinera pas
l'embauche sur l'accord la corde sur la
coque de la valeur on est sur autre
chose le salaire rémunère le travail
fourni le partage de la valeur on est
sur des objectifs une performance
collective on n'est plus du tout sur la
même dimension donc c'est un à côté qui
doit aucunement venir d'accord si tu
veux augmentation salariale
prochain là après retraite c'est le
Conseil constitutionnel arrive avec un
projet de loi qui viendrait quand pour
terminer sur l'emploi et ces questions
là le le projet de loi travail pour
l'instant il est plutôt aux alentours de
l'été c'est un peu je bote un peu en
tout genre
on n'a pas des précisions plus claires
sur écouter je vous propose de vous
réinviter le rat du concret la
transposition de l'accord
national interprofessionnel qui ont
signé les partenaires sociaux on est en
train de regarder si on peut le faire
beaucoup plus rapidement et pour
favoriser justement
son application le plus rapidement parce
que les partenaires sont aussi rappelé
dans cet accord la prépondérance que
doivent avoir les négociations sur les
bases conventionnelles c'est dit merci
beaucoup merci pour ce débat très
éclairant technique mais je crois qu'on
a pu voilà mieux comprendre merci à vous
d'être venu sur LCP vous restez avec moi
Serge Julie dans une dizaine de minutes
les parties primes nos affranchis
ce soir ils sont déjà là ils se
préparent Isabelle Lasserre du Figaro
qui va revenir sur le tollé occidental
après le faux pas d'Emmanuel Macron sur
Taïwan la polémique ne désenfle pas bien
au contraire Carole Barjon de lobbs va
pousser un coup de gueule sur
l'enseignement de la grammaire en grande
déshérence à l'école et puis à Marco
polonais dans bobo Express va nous
dresser le bilan de nos engagements à
tenir pour arriver à l'accord de Paris
sur le climat rapport parlementaire à
l'appui mais d'abord on va fêter un
anniversaire et quel anniversaire les 50
ans de libération voilà le hors série
exceptionnel qui sort demain dans les
kiosques 50 ans de combat 50 ans
d'engagement à gauche toujours mais pas
sans quelques ruptures on va voir tout
cela dans l'invitation signé Hélène
Bonduelle et on en parle ensemble juste
après
si on vous invite Serge Julie c'est pour
fêter un anniversaire avec vous
soufflez les 50 bougies du journal
Libération 50 ans de photos 50 ans de
combat
journaliste éditorialiste vous êtes
devenu la figure historique de Libé
depuis que vous l'avez cofondé avec le
philosophe Jean-Paul Sartre en 73 avant
d'en prendre la direction pendant 33 ans
[Musique]
prenez votre journal en main dès son
premier numéro le quotidien donne le ton
et vous aussi il y a un pari de
libération qui est celui de
l'indépendance totale c'est-à-dire quand
on écrit quelque chose vous pouvez avoir
la garantie que c'est totalement libre
un journal sans publicité ancrée très à
gauche et qui suit les secousses et les
avancées de la société française les
ventes grimpent rapidement mais en 81 le
journal traverse plusieurs crises
disparaît des kiosques pendant quelques
semaines et revient juste après
l'élection de François Mitterrand
nouvelle maquette nouveau style et
nouveau logo
on a fait le logo qui était la marque
qui était un signe qui distanciait par
rapport à l'ancienne parce que
Libération c'est un mode de vie ce logo
là on peut presque le porter sur soi
libération ça peut se porter comme des
vêtements une petite raille ciselée
des photos percutantes pour des une
culte Libé c'est un style un état
d'esprit aussi comme en 2015 lorsque le
quotidien accueille dans ses locaux les
journalistes de Charlie Hebdo quelques
jours après les attentats
vous restez là Serge Julie vous avez
accompagné chaque étape du quotidien de
la gloire aux difficultés jusqu'à être
poussé vers la sortie en 2006
alors à 50 ans libération est-il
toujours un adolescent révolté et vous
Serge Julie 17 ans après avoir été
évincé du quotidien qu'est-ce qui vous
pousse à reprendre la plume dans les
colonnes de Libé
mais ça reste à jamais votre journal ou
pas je lis tous les jours mais on peut
imaginer que je lis beaucoup de journaux
tous les jours voilà ma passion sont les
journaux voilà l'histoire de libération
c'est il faut jamais oublier que
nous nous venons dans un moment c'est
après 68 où il y a une mutation de la
presse formidable et Libération ce
projet qu'on lance qui aille peu de peu
de moyens tout ça on est en avance sur
la modernisation
la technologie de la presse donc
je venais voir des gens pour dire vous
savez on va lancer un quotidien j'en
disais mais si ça coûte un milliard ça
coûte 2 milliards de francs vous pouvez
vous allez trouver ça personne je vous
les donneras jamais
et alors moi je répondais vous savez on
a notre idée c'est que la technologie on
a deux machines ça nous suffit on n'a
pas besoin d'avoir une usine avec du
plomb et Libération on a été très
moderne très en avant dans la
modernisation informatique de la presse
si le titre c'est vous le titre même si
le titre même si c'est vous qui en êtes
à l'origine c'est plutôt un emprunt il a
fallu
c'est un emprunt c'est un don c'est la
famille de d'acier de la Vigerie qui
était celui qui pendant la résistance à
diriger le mouvement Libération alors
plutôt Libération Sud d'ailleurs sans
entrer dans les détails et donc qui
était associé à sa personne et donc
quand libération épanouie d'asser la
Vigerie était mort mais ça veuve ses
enfants étaient toujours vivants et donc
le premier numéro de libération est paru
avec un petit encart de la famille
d'acier Lavigerie qui est disait
pourquoi il à la fois ça n'avait rien à
voir avec l'histoire d'Emmanuel d'acier
lavillerie mais en même temps la famille
soutenait ce projet donner la parole au
peuple permettre au peuple d'écrire sa
langue ça c'est le contrat initial on va
faire l'inventaire des combats entre
continuité et rupture le fil rouge des
engagements de Libé me semble-t-il ce
sont les luttes sociales aujourd'hui
l'opposition à la réforme des retraites
en 73 on a retrouvé les les ouvriers
regarder de Lip joyeux Noël à lip le
directeur d'adore c'est Jean-Paul Sartre
on est en 73 l'année de la naissance du
journal et Libé est invité à fêter avec
les ouvriers de cette usine de montre là
c'est aux côtés des travailleurs dans
tous les conflits du travail que vous
voulez être
c'est pas pour le plaisir mais de vous
contredire
libération c'est l'enfant de 68 donc
c'est une génération alors ça aide quand
on a on part avec un public potentiel ce
qui intéresse libération et ce qui va
faire son anciennement dans la société
française c'est à la fois ce qu'on
appelle le sociétal les la société de
manière dont elle bouge et puis la
culture voilà alors vous pouvez me dire
enfin c'est quand même la politique qui
vous intéresse oui mais c'est pas ce qui
fait la pendant des années
l'enracinement de libération le sociétal
on va parler du féminisme on va parler
de la question des minorités la gauche
est-ce qu'on peut dire la gauche
toujours l'extrême droite jamais on va
on a gardé deux une regardée
heureusement qu'on fait pas les 980
l'aventure ça c'est la Renaissance
du journal zéro que nous faisons
avec pour la reparution donc c'est le on
fait ça le dimanche
le
François Mitterrand vient d'être élu
je vais vous raconter une anecdote sur
Mitterrand
Mitterrand se présente en 65 j'étais à
l'époque
vice-président de l'UNEF donc lunaire
fait
se pose la question est-ce que nous
soutenons François Mitterrand donc la
décision de lunaire c'était on ne
soutient pas François Mitterrand
pourquoi parce que toutes ces histoires
algériennes le rôle qu'il avait joué
tout ça c'était donc
je suis missionné par le fait d'aller
voir François Mitterrand et lui dire non
on va pas le soutenir ça c'est 65 en 74
on lance libération et Libération c'est
très fragile il y a des moments on
s'arrête voilà et la politique
occupe très peu de place dans le
libération de 74 donc c'est des brèves
c'est moi qui l'ai fait d'ailleurs c'est
des brèves sur la vie politique le
l'élection présidentielle on peut même
les spécialistes penchent sur le
libération de l'époque c'est très
marginal et
91 décide d'arrêter le journal pour le
transformer et donc
Mitterrand est élu je vais le voir et il
me dit mais vous m'en voulez puisque
chaque fois que je me présente
libération est pas là
bon voilà cette fois-ci vous y étiez
puisque vous retournez
la gauche le journal évidemment est à
gauche mais soutient parfois critique
toujours critique souvent quand ça
mérite il faut pas critique à tort et à
travers mais des périodes plus libérales
que aujourd'hui
le libération est d'abord on est très
indépendant enfin nous avons été très
indépendant je pense que le libération
d'aujourd'hui je ne suis qu'un
collaborateur d'une chronique et pas de
jeunes liberté de parler totale
mais en l'occurrence
voilà c'est pas parce que le président
est de gauche que voilà il faut avoir la
même exigence pour lui comme pour
Nicolas Sarkozy l'autre constante on en
a parlé les combat que c'est tout ce
sont les femmes le féminisme forcément
du MLF à la lutte contre les féminicides
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs Libé à contribuer
à faire basculer ce mot de féminicides
dans le langage commun depuis le début
les femmes la conquête du droit des
femmes des droits c'est l'ADN du journal
les femmes il y en avait toujours
beaucoup à la rédaction dès le début il
y en avait mais il y en a eu de plus en
plus voilà donc je suis oui j'ai assisté
à ça je l'ai peut-être encouragé j'ai
voilà je mais c'est indispensable vous
dites le mot féminicide il y avait un
moment donné les les gens de qui font le
dictionnaire Robert par exemple s'amuser
à avait nous avait fait des études sur
tous les mots introduits par Libération
les mots nouveaux
à ce point-là parce que la langue c'est
quelque chose de vivant et il y a des
nouveaux mots qui apparaissent ça aussi
c'est une manière d'être
dans l'actualité on va vous montrer les
combats sociétaux toujours d'ailleurs
très vigilant sur la question des
violences policières les mirration n'a
pas forcément les policiers au cœur on a
retrouvé plein de une
Saint-Germain la question des de la de
les avoir au pas au cœur la une police
c'est essentiel dans une démocratie il y
a pas de bonne démocratie sans politique
mais une police qui est dirigée par qui
est utilisé quand le gouvernement va mal
quand le gouvernement va mal il y a
toujours la tentation de montrer que on
a on a on est on est là pour l'ordre que
on assume l'ordre donc voilà je prends
un exemple qui était celui du préfet de
police pendant 68 je ferai un marquer
que en 68 à Paris il n'y a aucune
victime en mai 68 donc il y a pas de
souci voilà donc il y a pas de tuer les
forces bien sûr il y en a eu après
l'international ça ça vous tient à cœur
très important libération
internationale de d'envoyer spéciaux de
correspondant on y a toujours consacré
une partie importante du budget est-ce
qu'on peut dire que l'anti-totalitarisme
fait partie des origines ou c'est un peu
plus compliqué que ça est-ce que la
passion communiste des années 70-80 a pu
aveuglé par moment ce journal alors non
parce que Libération n'a pas eu la
passion communiste il a eu une passion
plutôt anticommuniste c'était la
libération de l'Europe de l'est parce
que l'Europe de l'Est il y a d'abord la
tchécoslova puis on soutient le
printemps tchèque
et puis
après
il y a évidemment
la chute disons la première chute de
l'empire soviétique la photo aussi ça il
faut absolument parler totalement à part
magnifique bouquin qui a été fait par le
l'oeil de Libé avec des photos
incroyables
et qui a été qui est une très belle idée
qu'ils ont eu de rassembler des photos
emblématiques qui ont été publiées par
Libération souvent commandée par
Libération
participer à cette aventure cette idée
géniale de mettre en une photo plein
cadre d'ailleurs beaucoup au copier
depuis avec
ce qui est arrivé souvent c'est le
format
ce format donnait la possibilité de de
faire un style de journal qui était un
peu différent ou à la fois pour le petit
train à la fois pour la photo voilà donc
je on dit on avait un une expression à
l'époque on disait on fait un quotidien
magazine
les conférences de rédaction vous en
avez connu beaucoup la réputation de
Libé c'est que on peut s'empoigner des
heures oui mais la contradiction est
importante et Salut Bonjour la ligne
aujourd'hui le libération est-ce qu'elle
vous elle vous convient ou parle un peu
d'une ligne mélange au kyste parfois
en l'occurrence
la contradiction c'est vital c'est la
vie et c'est essentiel en tout cas dans
un journal allez 50 ans de combat c'est
demain dans les kiosques et ce
magnifique album au seuil avec les plus
belles les plus belles photos de de Libé
50 ans d'anniversaire qu'on fait avec
vous merci les parties pris tout de
suite vous allez pouvoir et réagir on
accueille nos affranchis pour leur carte
blanche allez venez avec nous
Carole Barjon de lobs
bonsoir Isabelle Lasserre du Figaro
c'est à vous dans une minute mesdames et
on commence comme chaque soir par
Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée elle nous est racontée ce
soir par Marco pommier bonsoir Marco
bonsoir Myriam une question ce soir à la
France risque-t-elle une nouvelle
condamnation pour inaction à climatique
c'est ce que laisse entendre Antoine ver
Morel marquez à député les républicains
ce matin il présentait les conclusions
d'une mission d'information
parlementaire destinée à évaluer les
objectifs climatiques de la France ce
rapport il est là je l'ai entre les
mains conclusion Myriam notre pays ne
respecte pas l'accord de Paris signé en
si la France notamment en 2022 a baissé
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
2,5%, on rappelle que normalement
l'engagement annuel pour la France et de
l'ordre de 5% et donc on peut voir soit
le verre à moitié vide soit à moitié
plein mais on peut pas considérer que en
tout cas à ce jour la trajectoire qui
est la nôtre nous conduira à horizon
2030 à respecter l'accord de Paris
le message est clair les efforts de la
France seraient donc insuffisant la
baisse des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre et trop lente même s'il y a quand
même de bons élèves regardez entre 90 et
2020 à les secteurs de l'industrie du
bâtiment ou de l'agriculture ont baissé
leur empreinte carbone c'est pas le cas
en revanche des transports plus 9,5%
autre point noir les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre importé c'est à dire les
produits consommés en France mes
produits à l'étranger alors ça c'est
pour le constat pourquoi ce rapport
parlementaire et bien Myriam se rapporte
il a été souhaité par le début par le
groupe des Républicains en novembre
dernier c'était juste après une vidéo
d'Emmanuel Macron de publier sur les
réseaux sociaux souvenez-vous à l'époque
le chef de l'État répondait à des
internautes sur la question du climat il
avait réagi à la condamnation de la
France pour une action climatique et il
se dédouanait nous nous sommes fait
condamner pour inaction climatique sur
la période
2015-2018 vous êtes très sympathique
Melvin d'essayer de m'en coller une sur
Twitter mais la condamnation pour une
action climatique c'est plutôt pour la
période d'avant pas pour ma pomme c'est
pas pour ma pomme alors Emmanuel Macron
avait quand même reconnu
alors Emmanuel Macron avait quand même
reconnu que la France n’était pas au
rendez-vous sur la baisse des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre mais on avance
disait-il on avance certes mais vous
l'avez compris on est loin de nos
objectifs et côté proposition alors que
dis ce rapport 5 grandes recommandations
au total déclinées en plusieurs mesures
quelques exemples d'abord une loi de
planification écologique comme ça se
fait déjà pour l'armée l'organisation
chaque année au Parlement d'un débat sur
le climat le renforcement aussi du
secrétariat général à la planification
écologique actuellement ils sont
seulement 15 à travailler dans cet
instant autre piste la création d'un
dialogue environnemental késako écouter
c'est quoi ce dialogue environnemental
vous voulez mettre en place des
syndicats environnementaux alors c'est
un droit qui est garanti par la
Constitution à l'article 7 de la Charte
de l'environnement mais qui n'est jamais
exercé et au même titre que le dialogue
social ou quand vous avez besoin de
faire une grande réforme vous savez à
qui vous adressez là aujourd'hui en
matière climatique ou de biodiversité on
n'a pas d'acteurs vraiment identifié et
donc concrètement à quoi ça pourrait
ressembler concrètement ça voudrait dire
que les ONG les entreprises les
collectivités et tous les autres acteurs
se structurent pour avoir un seul
représentant et de façon à pouvoir
échanger avec le Parlement et le
gouvernement en amont des textes voilà
le député les républicains qui se veut
quand même optimiste c'est pas mort pour
le climat selon lui il rappelle
d'ailleurs que certains pays en Europe
aujourd'hui respectent leurs engagements
climatiques le Royaume-Uni le Danemark
ou encore la Suède merci beaucoup Marco
Isabelle Lasserre vous voulez revenir
sur le tolé occidental qui a provoqué
les propos de d'Emmanuel Macron sur sur
Taïwan 4 jours après son retour de Chine
la polémique de désenfle pas oui elle ne
désenflent pas sauf en Chine bien sûr ou
les propos tenus dans l'avion par le
président français qui visait surtout
les États-Unis accusés en fait de
d'envenimer la situation à Taïwan on
fait les chougras du Parti communiste et
de six in ping qui salue une parole de
vérité et à Washington bien sûr ou
certains républicains républicains
utilisent le faux pas d'Emmanuel Macron
pour servir leur agenda politique est
réclamé un allègement de l'engagement
américain en Ukraine Donald Trump qui
est en plein déboires judiciaire ainsi
sauter sur l'occasion pour accuser le
président français d'être allé en Chine
pour lécher les bottes de chez INPI mais
partout ailleurs par tout ailleurs chez
les alliés de la France c'est la
consternation en donnant l'impression
que la France resterait neutre et
silencieuse en cas d'annexion forcée de
Taïwan en plaçant en donnant
l'impression de placer la démocratie
américaine sur un même pied que la
dictature chinoise Emmanuel Macron a
déstabilisé tous ses partenaires du camp
occidental heureusement heureusement il
vient de faire une mise au point
aujourd'hui au Pays-Bas il a rappelé de
manière très claire et très ferme la
position officielle de la France qui est
pour le statu quo à Taïwan et il a
rappelé que la France était un allié des
États-Unis ça fait du bien alors est-ce
qu'il avait sur le fond raison ou tort
de dire qu'une guerre à Taïwan serait ni
celle de l'Europe ni celle de la rime et
non il a il a il n'a pas raison parce
que de la même manière que les
Américains depuis Barack Obama essaye de
s'extraire de l'Europe et qu'il n'y
arrive pas parce qu'ils sont toujours
attrapés par les crises et les guerres
du vieux continent on le voit
aujourd'hui en Ukraine la France ne
pourra pas faire l'autruche en cas de
guerre contre Taïwan d'abord est-ce
qu'elle est une puissance un membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU une puissance nucléaire qu'ensuite
elle se positionne comme une puissance
en indo-facifique c'est le seul pays de
l'Union européenne qui est des
possessions dans la région des
territoires dans la région et ensuite
parce qu'une déflagration à Taïwan
aurait de telles conséquences
économiques que les conséquences
seraient terribles pour l'Europe le
président français donc reproduit les
mêmes erreurs selon vieux sur la Chine
que sur la Russie sans péché Myriam de
comparer la politique chinoise
d'Emmanuel Macron à la politique russe
dans les deux cas le président français
a pratiqué en même temps qui établit une
troublante et distance entre les deux
acteurs dans les deux cas il a surestimé
sa capacité d'influence sur les
dictateurs dans les deux cas il a
utilisé la persuasion alors que c'est
président ne comprennent que le rapport
de force et dans les deux cas il est
revenu bredouille de tous ces entretiens
et mépris par nos alliés
occidentaux d'un mot c'est une faute
qu'il a commise d'un mot très rapide oui
elle est un peu vite quoi Carole
j'ai remarqué pas uniquement dans ce
domaine
aussi histoire Carole vous voulez nous
parler de cette nouvelle grammaire qui
pourrait débarquer dans les écoles à
quoi va-t-elle ressembler je vous en
donne un exemple dans la phrase je vais
à Paris et bien à Paris devient un
complément d'objet indirect du verbe
aller et non plus du tout un complément
de lieu comme le constant encore
naïvement une grande majorité française
et comme nous le pensons encore vous et
moi c'est sûr pourquoi est-ce grave
parce que selon un collectif de
professeurs de l'association sauver les
lettres qui se revendiquent d'une gauche
républicaine et qui lance un appel au
ministre de l'éducation nationale cela
prive les élèves de repères même un
jeune enfant c'est que Paris est un lieu
et ça l'aide à raisonner du coup les
élèves auxquels on demande de se livrer
à des manipulations de groupes de mots
dans la phrase pour trouver la bonne
solution en sont réduit à tâtonner
telle origine de cette nouvelle
grammaire des universitaires ce sont les
universitaires qui ont initié presque
tous les changements dans les programmes
scolaires depuis quelques décennies et
les programmes scolaires du primaire or
les universitaires sont pour la plupart
des chercheurs le problème est qu'ils
appliquent au programme de l'école
primaire les méthodes de recherche qu'on
emploie à l'université et on s'en
souvient c'est ce qui s'était passé dans
les cours d'histoire on avait supprimé
la l'enseignement de la chronologie on
faisait faire des études thématiques du
genre les paysans à travers les âges etc
et on l'avait vu le résultat les élèves
ne savaient plus cyclovis étaient avant
ou après napoléonçait quelque chose à la
maison nouvelle grammaire déjà mise en
œuvre à l'école primaire
alors pour le moment il y a beaucoup de
profs qui résistent du coup le ministère
insiste et certains inspecteurs
régionaux menacent même de faire
indirectement pression sur les
professeurs en demandant au correcteur
d'examens de mal noté les élèves qui ne
donneraient pas les réponses
correspondant à la nouvelle terminologie
grammaticale ça semble à la fois honteux
et incroyable mais tout ça est raconté
sur le site de l'association sauver les
lettres et sur le site de l'Obs parce
qu'on a aussi publié leur tribune bon
bref c'est c'est quand même très grave
je suis un peu sur la tête il faut
savoir que aujourd'hui il y a déjà 20%
des élèves qui ne maîtrisent pas la
langue française à l'entrée en 6ème
cette nouvelle grammaire risque
d'aggraver encore la situation et
surtout de creuser davantage les
inégalités sociales on sait bien que
quand l'enseignement est trop complexe
ou trop abstrait ce sont toujours les
élèves des milieux défavorisés qui en
pâtissent les premiers les autres ceux
qui ont leur chance d'avoir des parents
capables de les aider à surmonter les
difficultés rencontrer à l'école ils
sont sortiront toujours bon donc il y a
eu vraiment urgence à renoncer à cette
innovation grammaticale c'est assez
simple en fait il suffit d'une décision
du ministre et pour une fois ça ne
coûterait rien au budget de l'État mais
très bien mais
bon on en est là
à peine monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale le message
la si infiniment Carole et Merci à VOUS
serg Julie d'être venu sur le plateau
LCP allez je remontre c'est magnifique
ouvrage 50 ans dans l'oeil de Libé c'est
dans les très bonnes librairies c'est
absolument magnifique et à consommer
sans modération et puis demande dans les
kiosques les 50 ans de combat entre
continuité et rupture votre journal de
coeur où vous êtes chroniqueur depuis
janvier dernier faire Julie merci à vous
très belle soirée documentaire qui
commence maintenant avec Jean-Pierre
Gratien à demain même lui même
[Musique]